jesse waters prime time doesn't believe
he's going to say anything different
than what he usually says about guns and
crime tonight
if history is any indication he's going
to attack the second amendment and say
dear don't wear kevlar vests
no one needs to have a weapon that can
fire over 30 40 50 even up to 100 rounds
unless you think the deer are wearing
kevlar vests
think about the mass shootings
as many as 100 rounds
it's a weapon of war
but no amendment
no amendment to the constitution is
absolute if i'm elected and or i'm
coming for you and gun manufacturers i'm
going to take you on so to to gun owners
out there who say well obama
administration means they're going to
come for my guns bingo you're right if
you have an assault weapon
the fact of the matter is they should be
illegal period
what we don't expect to hear much about
tonight is violence in america's inner
cities most of the mass shootings which
have taken place mass shootings are
defined as shootings where four or more
people are shot at a time take place
with handguns in urban america the
year's already been bloody with
homicides already on pace to top last
year's highs in many cities and the
summer hasn't even started yet
most of them you'll never hear about
these mass shootings they don't fit the
media's narrative according to the fbi's
latest data in 2020 there were more than
8 000 murders using handguns
but for some reason joe biden won't talk
about that
the gangs shooting at each other in the
south side of chicago aren't using
ar-15s
the guns they're using are hot guns
criminals don't follow the law
chicago has the strictest gun laws in
the country but it's the murder capital
of the country think about that for a
second 47 people were shot
just this last weekend there
this is the second mass shooting of the
weekend chicago police say at least six
people have been killed
but biden doesn't care if he did he'd
talk about it and neither does chicago's
mayor
when a reporter pointed out that the
city's violent rep is scaring away
taurus she completely lost it
the nonsense that you're spewing that
tourists aren't coming to our city all
you have to do is walk up and down
missions no sir no sir no sir you will
stop speaking you will stop speaking
you're you're what you're full of crap
and that's the nicest thing that i can
say i will not let you spoil this moment
it'd be nice if she got mad at the gang
slaughtering innocent kids on her
streets instead of the reporters asking
questions about it
it's not just chicago though remember
philadelphia's d.a larry krasner he said
the city doesn't have a crime problem
there is not
a big spike in crime that is not true
there is also not a big spike in violent
crime neither one of these things is
true we don't have a crisis of
lawlessness we don't have a crisis of
crime we don't have a crisis of violence
fast forward to this weekend over 40
people were shot in philly my hometown
sounds like a crisis to me larry
pretending violence isn't real leaves
more innocent people dead and tightening
gun laws just means the only people who
can get guns are criminals
we need common sense solutions not the
same old ideas that have been making the
entire country more dangerous year after
year
is biden ready to look at the facts and
protect americans
i've laid out on the air specific
policies to harden schools and beef up
red flag laws these are easy common
sense solutions all americans can agree
on
we've also discussed on the show the
need to keep violent criminals off the
streets
and we've also discussed the attack on
masculinity in america how the toxic
internet and coveted shutdowns are
polluting people's minds
the politicians just need to get it
together and do their job now
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else